Hey!
Hello there, haven't seen you in ages!
Oh, all right yeah.
Great to see you again, you're looking really well!
Oh, you think so?
Thanks!
So, how are you?
Well, you know, mustn't grumble.
What've you been up to?
Still working in that coffee shop?
Yeah, same one.
Still trying to be an actor?
Well, yeah, you know...
So Hollywood hasn't called in yet?
Not yet.
Still living in that little flat?
Yeah, same one.
Well, great.
How about you, you still work in that fast food place?
No, stopped that a long time ago.
I'm working in the City now, financial industries.
Oh, great.
Are you still sharing that house with all those other people?
No way!
I bought a big house with four bedrooms and a garden, the works.
Good for you.
Listen, we should get together for a drink sometime, catch up.
Yeah, I'd love to.
Let's do it!
Keep in touch, you.
Yeah.